se mettre de la bière sur la peau avant
d'aller bronzer le birtaning bon déjà
c'est pas du tout sûr que ça marche
vraiment mais bref mais surtout bon être
bronzer c'est joli hein le soleil c'est
cool c'est pas le problème dans le
problème c'est les UV ah le gros
problème avec les UV c'est qui vous y la
peau si on se protège pas bon bah déjà
il donne des coups de soleil rien que ça
c'est pas ouf mais surtout à force bah
ils font vieillir notre peau plus vite
que prévu elle vient plus fine et on a
des tâches foncées et des rides qui
apparaissent beaucoup plus tôt que
normalement les UV ils bousille pas que
l'extérieur de notre peau ils abîme
aussi notre ADN et ça ça a deux
conséquences ça provoque des concerts de
la peau et ça affaiblit notre système
immunitaire ah oui et les UV ça nique
les tatouages aussi et donc le problème
avec la bière ça protège pas du tout les
UV pourtant des trucs qui nous protègent
des UV sans nous empêcher de bronzer on
en a un ça s'appelle de la crème solaire
après est-ce que vous préférez bronzer
plus vite et avoir l'air vieux plus vite
et choper un cancer et puis la bière
aussi parce que bon et attirer les
guêpes et les moustiques
c'est vous qui voyez